[Music]
keith is with us keith's in
orlando hi keith how are you hi dave
christie
honored to speak with you guys you too
what's up
so i find myself in a weird position
i've been calling the baby steps
and i've completed one two three and
four uh step five doesn't really apply
to me right now i'm single
not married uh no kids no plans for kids
and some years
and i have about twenty thousand dollars
extra in my savings account
while i'm working on step six paying off
my mortgage
um this is separate from my uh emergency
fund
and i wanna do either one of three
things with it this is where i'd like
your guidance
um would you like some options sure
okay so uh option one would be to throw
it all directly into my mortgage
um because i closed my house with only
five percent down on the third year
fixed i know that's against your wishes
i did this before as a ramsay listener
okay um
so doing that having a healthy appraised
option
option two is uh just invest it put in
the good mutual funds money market
account
have it grow that way or um option
three is kind of the careless one but
potentially just enjoy some of it
because i've been debt-free
for a long time without the mortgage
what do you make of your driver pretty
old
my base value is 85 but with commissions
last year was 183
this year i'm expecting about 150 000.
for you and what are you driving
i drive a 2007 fj cruiser okay
toyota what do you think christy um
you know i always go to this and this is
the opposite of what you always say but
i'm always like i like
dividing it up i'm like you can you can
play with a little bit of money put some
on your mortgage
invest some like i'm like i like just
kind of spreading it out when you've got
extra not obviously like when you got
you know when you're on a specific step
but
i don't know i would i would do no
investing
above 15 of your income anything that
you would have invested i would put
towards your mortgage i would split it
between
some enjoyment i think you need to
upgrade your car
and um when you're making 150 000 a year
you're driving a freaking hooptie
so i think you need i think you need to
move up about 10 grand in car
and uh if it were me now so here's the
thing when you're in baby steps four
five and six
you are not gazelle intense you are
instead
intentional and so what you're doing is
you're saying i'm going to be very
intentional with my dollars i'm going to
enjoy some i'm going to give some
i'm going to be investing my 15 and the
rest of it i'm gonna throw on a mortgage
and that's my intentionality and i i
think your past due to move up in car
and so uh if i woke up in your shoes i'd
probably spend about 10 grand on a car
and probably throw about 10 grand the
mortgage
but i i don't want to tell you ever to
do any investing beyond 15
until your mortgage is paid off so i'm
always going to throw it at the mortgage
or at some enjoyment but i think you've
got some things in your life that have
been put on hold back when you were in
baby steps one two and three and they
should have been on hold
then but now that you're at this stage
you should be intentional
not necessarily as intense does that
make sense
correct it does yeah uh one simple thing
awesome very quick if i would have if i
were to throw this 20 000
at my mortgage it would put me at uh
over 20 equity i could have the house
free appraised and it would get rid of
my pmi yeah
that's very tempting then but uh but
then you don't get a car
so i don't know you decide which one you
wanna do and when you wanna do it
all i care is you're doing it on purpose
that's the intentional part